- If anyone is on the
field and is disrespectful
to the anthem or the flag,
there would be a fine from
the league against the team.
(dramatic music)
- The NFL, without
the player's union...
- Knee capped.
- Has decided to attack
the lack of standing before
the National Anthem.
- We've listened to a lot
of different viewpoints,
including our fans' over the last year,
and I think this policy
attempts to come out in a place
where we respected everybody's
point of view in this.
- All 32 clubs...
want to make sure that during the moment
of the Anthem and the flag,
that that is a very important
moment to all of us,
as a league, as clubs,
personally and to our country.
- You have to stand proudly
for the National Anthem,
or you shouldn't be playing,
you shouldn't be there.
Maybe you shouldn't be in the country.
You have to stand proudly
for the National Anthem.
- There's been incredible engagement
with the players on this.
We've talked to tens, if
not hundreds of players
about this over the last year or so,
to get their input, to
understand their positions.
- All players who are on the
field when the National Anthem
plays must stand or face fines.
Mike Pence celebrated
with a spontaneous tweet,
"Hashtag winning."
Well, maybe not so fast, Mike Pence.
(dramatic music)